this is freedom you know people be being
able to grow their own marijuana at home
this is the end of the cannabis campaign
I mean we're seeing the new law in
action people are picking up free seeds
from people willing to share them and
they're gonna go home and they're gonna
grow marijuana and their homes in
Washington DC
I think we're giving enough seeds away
today for twenty thousand plants after
DC residents voted in favor a ballot
initiative 71 legalizing the possession
of marijuana the DC cannabis campaign
held a seed sharing event at the bar
libertine you know it's a very big space
but there are a couple dozen people up
top that are have seeds to share the
occasion drew media attention
Gawker's and a line blocks long I've
been waiting in line for two hours for
free marijuana seeds so I can begin
cultivating I'm hoping to get a nice
batch of seeds it's hot
you know it's we're free to drink
alcohol we're afraid to do everything
else it's legal so why not take
advantage of it yeah this really shows
them how far we've come that we were
able to do this and it just shows to
show how popular the issue is when you
have you know a thousand people waiting
in line for free seeds